okay here's the president of eurasia
group my old job
and g zero media who hosts pbs's g-zero
world with ian bremmer
ian bremmer not surprisingly
okay and she's the former senior
pentagon official my other old job under
president obama and
author of the new book tangled up in
blue policing the american city
rosa brooks is over here
okay well you know with all the policing
that was in the news
uh last week or so i said to my staff i
said can you book me
a brilliant journalist who quit her job
in her 40s to actually become a cop just
give me a list
and you were the only one on the list i
shouldn't even have been on the list
phil i didn't actually quit myself
but you actually became a cop i did and
can
what did you learn from that experience
that would help us get through this
difficult
moment in american history so i learned
here's a dirty little secret about cops
that
they don't really get much training and
how to use their weapons
when i went through the police academy
we had two weeks of firearms training
uh first week was just in the classroom
second week about three hours a day on
the range and then you qualify you're
done
twice a year you re-qualify you watch a
few powerpoint slides as a refresher and
you're done so this is
about the amount of what i put in yeah
yeah so we've got a lot of people
walking around with lethal weapons who
don't really know what they're doing
interesting
and it seemed to me the theme a lot of
it was that
cynicism yeah is really
the overarching problem i mean racism is
part of it
a lot of things are part of it but
they're just beaten down
we ask cops to be social workers and
medics and warriors and mediators and
any one of those jobs is really hard and
most people can't do any one of those
jobs
really well if you ask some 25 year old
to do all of them in the same 10 hour
shift
they're going to do them really badly
yeah and and
you know suicide kills more cops every
single year
than every other cause combined did you
see pat robertson
is uh speaking out against the cops i
mean
he came across as woke in that interview
that's the only time i would ever use
that word
i don't know if he's literally woke
i it's i mean come on i mean
it's not you also said you think most
cops are decent compassionate people
yeah
you know most right i do too don't wake
up in the morning saying
go some people's lives up today
yeah you people do a few people do some
do
don't but they're working in a system
that even if you're a good cop you're
going to screw people's lives up
you